Democratic front-runner Joe Biden
recently sketched his education agenda for 2020.
He promises to triple federal spending on
districts with large numbers of low-income
students, double the number of health professionals
in schools, provide universal pre-K, embrace
race-based policies, and even “defeat”
the NRA.
There’s not a mention of accountability
or of charter schools.
This would be the most liberal
education agenda in American history.
But remarkably, compared to his presidential
rivals, Biden’s plan looks centrist, and
rather modest.
Key Democratic rivals have promised hundreds
of billions in new education spending.
Both parties have long wooed the center when
it came to education.
It’s how Republicans showed their soft side
and Democrats like President Obama showed
their reformist bona fides.
But, today, President Trump oversees arguably
the most conservative Department of Education
in history, and Democrats have responded in
kind.
Whoever wins in November 2020, federal education
policy looks set to be an increasingly partisan affair.
Do you think education's going
to be a partisan issue in 2020?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.